hello  and greetings people of earth  i am here of my own  free will for sure most definitely  100 percent a mundo  uh to uh let you know the the people  know that markiplier is  um he's real he's he's very real  could not be more real definitely not  fake  he is real really real all of the  uh unsubstantiated claims that he is not  real  are false trust me duders  we have known each other for at least  this meant this  many years it's been many many years  it's been made a long time a very long  time because he's very real  too many years to count  here is a photo of us together  showing he is real the lighting  not great but that's really him  uh you have my word  it is really really him because he's  real and  not not fake  uh so thank you for your time  please go now please let me go